welcome eduardo eduardo is interested in
developing tools to deliver reliable
machine learning products towards that
end develop plumer an open source python
library for reproducible data science
first introduced at jupitercon 2020.
he holds a master of science in data
science from columbia university where
he took part in computational
neuroscience research he started his
data science career in 2015 at the
center for data science and public
policy at the university of chicago
eduardo is going to talk about effective
testing for machine learning projects
yes that's correct
awesome great so let's get started um
thanks everyone for joining today um we
are going to be talking about effective
testing for machine learning uh my name
is eduardo blancas and i'm really happy
to be here
so thanks thanks for joining let's start
with this presentation
so before we get into the details um i
want to like kind of discuss the
motivation for this for this um for this
talk because why should we bother about
testing right you you come to a talk um
and i'm going to be talking about
testing and and why should we bother
about these things and over the years
since i've been working on many
different data science and machine
learning projects i often ask this
question to other people to say what
they think
and sometimes they give these these
kinds of like really valid answers and
they say well i don't have enough time
right if i'm working on a model and i
want to improve that model um testing is
going to slow me down and i'm not going
to be able to run enough experiments and
that's a really valid concern sometimes
they say i don't know i don't know how
to test these things it's very very
different to test let's say an api
from a regular web application
it's much difficult to think how do i
test a machine learning model so these
are really valid answers and concerns so
the idea of this talk is to give some
some of my perspective of what i've
learned over the years
and maybe you can you can take some of
these and apply to your projects and
really the question should be
where do you want to find the issues
right because we we are humans we make
mistakes so if if you don't test you're
going to find those issues in production
so do you rather test to find them in
development or production so that's i
think that's really the question that we
should be asking and another thing that
i've learned over these last few years
is that when you start testing and you
feel comfortable adding tests to your
code
it really has
uh it increases your productivity
because you are able to confidently make
changes to your code without worrying am
i gonna make some mistake am i going to
um drop the performance of my model
because i introduced some error at some
point so really having these tests allow
you to say okay if my tests are passing
then it means that i'm making good
progress so um
i think the bottom line from this from
this slide is it's important and it
helps you in the long run so please test
now why am i calling this an effective
approach
because i feel like
based on my experience we have to find a
good balance between
training
lots of models and experimenting trying
trying out new features
and at the same time add some more
robustness to our pipeline so they go
hand in hand it's not like we are going
to spend 100 of our time developing
models and then just add a few tests at
the end because that's not a good
strategy what we want to do is to do
some modeling then add a few tests and
continue working and the idea is that by
the time you are um
you want to deploy your model at that
point you have a really comprehensive
and robust test to it so that's that's
the idea here
now before i start talking about this
this practical framework i want to
introduce some really simple concepts
that i'm going to be using throughout
the presentation the first one is a
pipeline and a pipeline is a really
simple concept it's just a set of tasks
that have certain order of execution so
if we talk about the machine learning
pipeline we may have um like the the
basic structure of a machine learning
pipeline is we get some historical data
for for training purposes we get some
historical data um we generate some
features and then we train a model right
like really simple standard things now
inside the pipeline we have we have
tasks and a task is just a unit of work
it can be a function can be a script can
be a notebook it's kind of an arbitrary
definition but we organize our pipeline
in small tasks and it's really important
to do this to organize them in small
tasks so we can test them in isolation
so just bear in mind um that um this is
like a really genetic definition but
it's useful for for our purposes
now
if we
mention the pipeline concept we also
have to make some
important specifications for the machine
learning
projects that that we work on and is
that we usually have two pipelines the
first one is the training pipeline which
is what i mentioned before we get some
historical data we generate some
features and then we train a model
once we have that model we want to use
that to make predictions so now we have
our serving pipeline which is pretty
similar actually but instead of getting
historical data we get new data those
new data points that we want to use to
generate predictions and then we
generate the same
features we apply the same preprocessing
and then we use our model to make
predictions so as you can see this part
in the middle is the same thing and it's
really important to make that
specification because we want to make
sure that this the pre-processing is the
same at training and serving time
and i'm going to mention this again um
in one of the
last stages of the presentation it's a
really important distinction
now i the the code that i'm going to be
using for the presentation is available
on github so um you can maybe get it now
and
take a look at some of the code or you
can just follow the presentation and
maybe after the talk you can get the
code and play around with it run it
break it and see that you are able to
run the tests and i also configure
github actions so that you can see the
continuous integration thing
so hope you can get the code and enjoy
and play around with it so now let's get
started with the actual framework and
i developed this framework over um like
a couple of years i i couldn't find like
a really clear way of explaining
how i was testing my code until like a
few years of experimenting trying out
new things
um
and i think i finally after after a few
years i got this this clear idea of okay
we have to do this in different levels
and as we make progress we generate more
uh more robust tests so i think this is
this i would say this is the sim um like
the summary of my experience
and that's why i want to share that with
you so we are going to have five
different levels and the idea is that as
we make progress on our project we want
to keep increasing and increasing the
the robustness of our tests so let's
start with the first one the first one
is called smoke testing and this is the
most basic type of testing that we can
apply and it's called smoke testing
because we are
not
testing the output we are not doing
anything specific we are just making
sure that our code runs so this is the
most basic thing ima imagine you
just started working on a machine
learning project and you have some code
that maybe gets some data clean some
data you generate your first couple
features you want to make sure that you
are able to get a clean
um
server install your dependencies and run
your code
now
a really important uh question that you
may have is well if i have um 10
gigabytes of data or maybe even more
like one terabyte of data how am i going
to be testing this continuously because
the idea is that you should be testing
every time you push to your repository
so that's a really important thing you
should be testing continuously with each
change so you might be asking how am i
supposed to test my stuff if i
make 20 commits a day well the answer is
really simple you can test with a random
sample so if you have one million
observations just
grab a sample of one percent or even
less than that and test with that
because remember right now we we are not
worrying about the output of our code we
simply want to make sure that it runs
and just to make this uh concept a
little bit more
clear i'm going to show you how this
looks like in practice so
on your left
side you have the
configuration file that i'm using on
github to execute
a certain code every time i push to my
repo and i have a one branch per level
so you can see on your right side that
i'm in the first branch so one smoke
testing and this is how my code looks
like uh my my actual code is on a
notebook the details aren't important so
just
keep this in mind all my my work is in a
jupiter notebook and i get some data and
i train a model
and that's that's all i have
right now so what i'm doing here is i'm
using plumber the project that i'm
working on which allows me to quickly
run my notebook to make sure that it's
working so this is github actions and
we can ignore the details for now just
focus on this this part what i'm doing
is
every time i push to github i'm going to
install my dependencies you can see that
name install dependencies and then i'm
going to run my pipeline
that's that's it that's all i'm doing
and this really simple trick is a huge
progress for testing i'm just making
sure that things run that's why it's
called smoke testing
okay so moving on now we got to level
number two
maybe at this point you have more
features uh maybe you even have your
first baseline model so you should be
thinking
of how do i make sure that
the data that goes into my training
pipeline is of high quality
because if you have issues with the data
uh can be issues from the source maybe
the data
collection process isn't good enough and
you have some um corrupted data that
that can happen
so at this point we start to think about
the quality of the data
of what what goes in into our training
pipeline but also how can we make sure
that the kind the transformations that
we apply to our data
are implemented correctly so this second
level has two objectives the first one
is prevent
low quality data from entering our
training
pipeline and the second one is that we
want to detect issues with our data
transformations and our data
transformations can be something like a
group by and maybe we are doing some
some other
small tweaks to the data and we want to
make sure that those are implemented
correctly
so now let me show you how this looks
like in practice
um let me go to my file
and since we have limited time i'm i'm
not gonna be showing all the files
i'm just gonna be focusing on i have to
change my
branch first okay two integration that's
why i couldn't find the file okay tests
quality
okay so
uh just to give some more context of
what this sample pipeline is about i'm
using the heart disease data set that's
a sample data set and i i got this uh
really nice notebook from kaggle
and then i started just adding some
tests so what's the idea
in our pipeline we have a script that
cleans the raw data so we apply some
some transformations and the output of
that clean script is
our clean data now the definition of
clean data is subjective and it also
depends on the specifics of our data
sets so it's up to us as a data
scientist to define what clean data
means now we may say
for this data set we have an h column
and we have a sex column right that's
how the data is and we may define some
things like okay if this
data set has one person per row and we
have an h column when well one sensible
thing to say is that
all the observations all the values
on this column should be at least zero
right that that's a good rule to have
now we should automate testing for these
kinds of things
because
it might be the case that
we check our data when we are exploring
we are we have some jupyter notebook we
are exploring data and we check that we
say okay everyone in our data set has an
age of
like between 20 and 70 just to say
something right and it makes sense but
what happens if we make some mistake in
our transformations or we get some
corrupted observations
from the data warehouse we have to make
sure that every time we train a model
we have these rules in place because
these are kind of stop checks that
prevent us from training on low quality
data and i'm implementing this with
plumber because it allows me to
run something and then run this function
that checks the output of that script
but you can really implement this with
any framework
just you just have to uh like
have that concept clear you have some
script that produces some output and now
we want to check how the output looks
like now i also mentioned that this is
also this is integration testing and
some people also call it data quality
testing so it's the same thing i also
mentioned that at this point we are
going to start incorporating unit tests
and this is like a really traditional
like well-known concept
um so imagine that you are
developing some data transformations and
that you have a column
that has an integer
for example here
let's imagine that these are the values
that you have for for that specific
column
and then you want to convert those
values
to some human readable representation
and i got these values from the um
from the documentation from this data
set now this is a really simple
transformation so in many cases if you
are just doing like a really simple
stuff uh might not be worth your time to
inve uh to write a test if you have one
or two lines of code right especially if
you are using some other framework like
pandas that you know have correct
implementations of all these things but
whenever you have some custom
transformations or like some really
specific logic it's really important to
write some unit tests and a unit test
course like works like this you have a
function now you have a function that
does something with some input
so to write your test you define some
input
and then you define what's the expected
output of that function
given this input
and then you call that function with
that input
and verify that it's the same thing that
you expected
and if this happens that means your
tests are working if this fails then it
means that you should have like you
should go back to your implementation
and see what's going on so i can show
you how i can run my unit tests i only
have one but you should be implementing
this for all your custom data
transformations
i'm using this library called pythest
and i can execute pythest
and it can run it it runs my my single
test and it says it's working so i'm
happy my implementation is correct so we
can move on okay so let's go back to our
slides and talk about the level number
three so this is where things start to
get serious um and we start to write
some more robust tests so when i talk
about integration testing and data
quality one of the things that i
mentioned is we can check some of the
values in our columns or for example if
it's a categorical variable that we may
only have two or three values and we can
test for that or if it's like an h
column we should expect that to be
larger than a zero
but these are really basic things right
we are not saying we are only making
assumptions about
each individual column but we are not
saying anything about the overall
population
and changes in the data distribution
can break our models so imagine that we
are training this model that predicts
heart disease
right and we have information on let's
say that
focus on this first uh first curve that
we have here and imagine that we have
something like this that our dataset has
people uh who's between
um like the mean of this distribution is
50 50 years old and that's fine we train
a model we evaluate performance and it
works fine
now
we want to retrain our model let's say
we got some new data we got some um more
recent data from let's say a thousand
new people
um
and then our distribution looks like
this
this is a really drastic change and it
it can be valid it can be that simply we
are collecting data in a different way
and that's just how it is we have to
adapt to the change but it can also be
an issue and we don't know and if we
don't know the best thing
um to do
is to make sure that we detect these
types of changes like if we have some
key variables that we need to pay close
attention to
we have to make sure that whenever these
have drastic
changes
we test for that and raise an issue an
error if that's the case
so that's the first part the second part
is that we are going to start testing
our serving pipeline so at this point we
may have a good model a model that we
want to take to production that we want
to use for making predictions so we are
going to start adding these distribution
changes tests but also we are going to
make sure that we can train a model we
can take that model file and then we can
generate predictions so let's see how
the code looks like let me move to the
next branch okay so the first thing let
me show you how the
configuration file for github actions
looks like
first we run our unit tests and the
order is important here because the unit
tests are supposed to be fast so if they
fail we are going to stop execution
right here and it may take like one or
two minutes and that's great we want to
fail fast if if things are breaking we
want to um know as soon as we can
then the next thing that we do is we run
our training pipeline and remember we
are we are not checking um well at this
point we are we are checking some of the
properties of our data so uh if you are
able if you want to sample your data to
make things faster
you can still do it right if you are
checking um
the distribution of your data
um
these changes in distribution you can
also detect them with a sample of the
data but maybe you can run this instead
of every on every commit and push maybe
you can run this every night or every
week whatever works for you
and then what we are going to do is we
are going to run our serving pipeline so
check what's happening here i am
training a model
and then i'm taking that model
and then i'm running my serving pipeline
so of course i'm using uh this library
so i'm not going to go into the details
because that's going to take too much
time
uh but just take that idea
train your to train your model you take
that same model and then put it in
inside your serving pipeline and make
sure that you can generate some
predictions can can be with some um
sample data that you have um you just
want to make sure that you can actually
take that model and generate predictions
now i'm going to show you the example of
this distribution changes test
so remember in the previous um
level i i told you about these data
quality tests
the changes in distribution are just an
extension of that idea but we are
testing a more specific thing
so here what i'm running is i'm running
a statistical test
the details you can check the details on
on wikipedia
but the idea the high level idea is that
if the distribution changes too much i'm
going to set a threshold
and if that difference goes beyond that
threshold
i'm going to raise an error we are
expecting changes to happen like if we
have a hundred observations and tomorrow
we get ten new observations it's natural
that we are gonna see some small changes
in the distribution and that's fine and
we don't want to raise issues for those
uh or race errors for those small
changes so that's why we set a threshold
here and here we start to think about
these kinds of threshold which to be
honest are hard
to to set
but my recommendation is keep things
simple
come up with some threshold and if it
doesn't work that well
you you can adjust it so um that's why
it's this is like a really practical
framework we want to make things fast we
want to make things practical but if
things don't work for you because you
have a complex data set you may you may
have to tweak um
these kinds of tests for your use case
okay so
moving on to the next level
we are now at level four which is um one
of the most important things to do so
make sure that you
create this test before you deployed
production
so let's recap our definition of
training and serving pipelines this the
training pipeline generates
a uh a model a train model and the
serving pipeline takes that model
and generates prediction
predictions right
but from the moment we get the data
until the moment that we either train a
model or generate predictions we have to
apply some pre-processing and we have to
make sure that that pre-processing is
the same exact same thing
a training and serving time and to give
you an example of what can happen is
let's imagine that we get some data
point and that data point is one two
three
we pass that data point through our
training pipeline this is before we
train the model this is the fitter
vector that we use for training the
model
and we get an output of 10
20 30. okay now we take that same data
point
we pass it through our pre-processing
for serving and we get 10 20 40. this is
a problem
because given the same input both our
training and serving pipeline should
have the same output and this is a
really common problem and this happens
many many times so what we do is we
generate some or it can be some sample
data from your training set or you can
generate some synthetic observations
it's the same thing what you have to
test is you write a little program you
write a test that takes this some input
passes through your training and serving
pipeline and then check that these
values are are the same for i don't know
like 10 20 data points or even more if
you if you can afford um a larger
running time so this is a really
important test to have i'm not going to
show the code because it has a little
bit more details uh but you you get the
general idea
so really important test
now we are uh
this is the final level uh in our
framework and and here we are going to
start testing model quality so this is
really really important and
also you have to make sure that before
you go to production you have this test
in place so let me go to our code and
quickly move to
the last
eduardo just a quick heads up we have
about five minutes left
okay yeah yeah almost done thanks
um okay so
this is this is the idea we have
we have to make sure that everything
that comes out from our training
pipeline is a model of good quality
right because many things may happen we
may
for for imagine
accidentally we've removed some of the
most important features in our model or
we lick some information from the filter
information that we are not going to
have at prediction time like there are
many many things that can drop the
performance of our model and if we are
not closely monitoring these changes we
can
deploy models that are not of high
quality so really simple idea here we
train a model we get the predictions
this is from our evaluation set we get
the prediction
predictions we get the actual values and
then we test that some metric the the
specific metric depends on our model
we check that the the metric is within
certain range
and it's important to make it between i
have like the the two bounce the lower
and the upper bound because if if a
model suddenly drops in performance
that's a bad thing
if it's suddenly
it's like crazily good from one moment
to another then that might be great news
that might be i'm sure it's because
you're a great data scientist but you
know even great data scientists may make
mistakes so make sure that if you
get high
increases in performance is because you
have some
greater model instead of doing some some
mistake because it happens to everyone
so how do you come up with this uh range
i mean to be honest it's kind of
arbitrary and i would recommend you to
just uh kind of draw some some
reasonable range and if you um if you
can if it works for you then that's fine
if you have more complexity like same
thing that i mentioned before if your
project is more complex and you have
more stuff going on uh you can pre-visit
some statistics books or or you can chat
to me and and i'm always happy to talk
about these kinds of things and come up
with some more statistically principled
way of drawing these boundaries but this
is the simple idea test the performance
of your model
and here are a few resources just to end
the the presentation you go you can get
the code from here and i'm gonna prepare
a blog post from all of this
presentation with more examples with
more details so please check out keep an
eye on on the blog you have that here um
if you want to check out bloomberg which
was the framework that i use for the
code examples uh you can also get it on
github and
i'm gonna take questions now but if you
want to ask anything after the
conference you can reach out to me on
twitter and that's it i we still have a
few minutes for questions thank you so
much eduardo um we have a question from
felipe do you run the tests in different
branches
that's a great question i think it
depends on how many people are working
on that project if you are collaborating
then it would make sense to have like
different for different features
different branches and then when you
merge you run everything
um so i would say it's more like a team
strategy
okay and philippa also would like to
know if the data quality integration
tests need to be run for the entire data
set
yes that's also a great point i would
recommend you to run them with the
sample every time you push but if you
can allow
um maybe run this integration test on
like every night or every week if you
are dealing with like large large data
sets that's also a good idea
okay
thanks patrick would like to know um you
showed some github actions are you
running all these tests remotely if so
for example for the data quality checks
how do you store your data sets
that's an important question and i i
kind of skipped that setup for uh to
simplify the the examples so right what
i'm using is a really sample data set
that has like 100 observations or so in
a real setting
uh then you would have to think about
the infrastructure right how do you make
sure that when you push your code
whatever whatever computing
infrastructure that you are using is
able to get your data and then from your
code so that that's a really important
question um i would say that's that's
more like in the infrastructure side but
that's definitely something that you can
you need to think of when you implement
this this framework
okay
thank you eduardo there's so many great
questions and unfortunately we didn't
have time to answer all of these but i
want to thank you for being a part of pi
data global 2021 thank you so much
thank you
bye